So, das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute.
So Leute soll ich euch mal was
soll ich euch mal was was wie soll ich sagen was was erfreuliches berichten
und zwar das was wir letzten zweimal im stream programmiert haben funktioniert
der cool champ ist am start und ich habe es jetzt getestet mit dem zweiten sensor
und das funktioniert zweiter sensor am start der elmann war schon vor ein paar tagen da
aber ich habe jetzt zwei sensoren dran und er erkennt automatisch die sensoren
und automatisch licht und temperatur und alles und ich kann jetzt meinen kühlschrank
überwachen äußerst nice ja der wie gesagt dhl war dhl war vor zwei tagen immer noch
aber heute samstag freitag am donderstag war der älter wann war der erste
ja am donderstag am donderstag war der älter gut es ist jetzt gerade ostern habe ich nichts
mehr von gehört april schätz von dhl sie haben eine lieferung zugestellt ja also kam
ich mir echt vor echt fail spare 25 prozent bei microsoft spring sale die
könne mich wüsste gleich was ich da kaufen sollt ja das macht mod check mod check den
haben wir sonst noch da oma omas drogen ist am start schon zwei monate kann der gut zu
funktionieren
ich persönlich denke das ist eher der psychologische effekt
wenn überhaupt also meine zweifel dass man dadurch
wirklich besser spielt man vielleicht bisschen himmelicher aber gerade an energy drinks
und generell koffein da gewünscht dich ja auch relativ schnell und bist dann eher merkwürdig
drauf wenn du mal wenn du mal keins hast aber für mich ist das nix weil ich trinke auch
kein kein kaffee und sowas das abgedrehteste was gaming booster booster abgeht was ich
bisher gesehen habe immer noch das hier das ist eine pille nicht also nicht kaulich nehmen
ja aber ich finde fand das produkt nur witzig das ist eine pille die kannst dir einschmeißen
wie omas drogen hier im chat gerade also nicht was die oma so nimmt und dann bist du viel
geiler danach ja und vor allem dass es irgendwelche pillen sind wenn die dich damit erwischen
denken sie erstmal wunder was das ist und die sagen auch nicht nur dass sie dass sie
gaming boosten sondern dass sie gegen dass sie gut sind für memory und brain für die
augen du siehst dann besser für bessere bessere bessere kacke weil ich glaube die meinen damit
eher dass die dass das die besser abbaubar sind also es ist schwachsinn es ist schwachsinn
und am besten war doch wo sie geschrieben haben hilft gegen ich wusste bis dahin dass
die stadt gar nicht dass das wort existiert hilft gegen mental fog also also vernebelt
vernebelte wahrnehmung ja mental fog wusste gar nicht dass das das das gibt schon mal
die vm an oder mache ich den ganzen kram mal zu wenn ihr wisst ja auf aliexpress gehe
ich am liebsten aus der vm ich kann dazu lustigerweise gar nicht viel sagen ich glaube kein kein
nix ist eine richtig neise geschichte wenn du halt was hast wo du das haus baust im hinblick
dessen also schon in dem hinblick dass du sowas haben willst also wenn du überall kabel
hast und sowas da ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt und auch eine überlegung wert du
kannst du kannst kein nix mit raspberry pi machen du kannst über home assistant ansteuern
so das ist das ist schon wohl relativ offen weiß ich die hardware ist wahrscheinlich
relativ teuer ich habe mich damit aber nie großartig beschäftigt weil mir schlicht
ergreifend die leitung fehlen das ist eine gute idee ja würde ich auch so machen wenn
ich scheiß baue sage ich das war mental fog genau das ist die beste beste begründung
überhaupt übrigens die beste begründung auf der arbeit ist wenn du was vergessen hast
du sagst es ist es ist erstaunlich wie gut das funktioniert wenn du wenn du hier auf
der arbeit richtig hacker mann machst und du verka du vergisst irgendwas oder das funktioniert
nicht so wie es ist und am ende kommt dann kommt dann einer sagt max das was du gemacht
das geht nicht richtig und dann dann muss man ihn fragen ja ok was meinst du was geht
nicht so genau und dann sagt er ja hier guck mal funktionen diese funktion ist gar nicht
drinnen da muss man einfach als antwort sagen wo steht das denn das war nicht im scope nicht
im scope ist eines der besten ausreden aller zeiten dass das das das ihr könnt was sagen
und es irritiert erst mal einfach zu allem sagen das war nicht im scope und wenn er
was gegenteil behaupten will dann muss er dann irgendwelche falls überhaupt so was existiert
irgendwelche meeting protokolle und sachen sich angucken wo besprochen wurde was angeblich
im scope ist einfach sagen nicht im scope einfach sagen nicht im scope und da seid
ihr zu 99 prozent raus diese ausrede funktioniert nicht bei in scope 21 ja gut der hat andere
probleme glaube ich ob der nicht im scope ist ja wahrscheinlich sowas in der richtung
ja übrigens auch eine super auch eine super ausrede wenn man auf der arbeit am start ist
und ich mache den ganzen krempel mal kurz zu alles klar da guck mal der baumuffant ist
immer noch anstatt ich starte mal neu mal gucken was es heute für den hintergrund bild
gibt ich muss dazu übrigens gar nicht neu starten fällt mir ein ich muss einfach das
kript ausführen ja aber reboot aber habt ihr habt ihr mal wie gut will c matrix für
windows beste anwendungszweck für wsl auch eine super auch eine super auch nicht mag
vertippt fast was auch eine super ausrede ist also auf der arbeit jetzt wenn einer wenn
einer fragt habt ihr ok heute sind leuchtturm als hintergrund wenn euch auf der arbeit einer
fragt so nach dem auto und wie sieht es damit aus bist du schon bist du schon vorwärts
gekommen das ist ja auch so eine so eine stonks frage und geht es voran so wie ist denn hier
der status und solche dinger dann ist die ultimative antwort da sind wir dran einfach
einfach auf alles wo ihr gar nicht wisst was der typ wollt oder wo ihr vergessen habt
einfach sagen das sind wir gerade dran und wenn er wenn er noch hartnäckiger ist und
wenn er noch hartnäckiger ist könnt ihr sagen ihr seid mit wir sind damit hochdruck
dran aber wir sind da dran reicht den meisten leuten schon um zu sagen ja gut wenn ihr
dran seid dann dann ist dann ist da gar kein problem dann dann macht man macht mal schön
ja da sind wir dran probiert das mal aus ohne scheiß es ist unglaublich wie oft das klappt
so also warum habe ich die eigentlich so viele fenster auf wir hatten früher dort wo ich
bei dem provider wo ich die ausbildung gemacht habe da hatten sie einen first level support
der halt der halt echt gar keinen plan hat das waren drei medels und die wurden halt
auch nicht dafür eingekauft plan zu haben die wurden die wurden dafür eingekauft dass
sie sich am telefon nett anhören dass die leute sich nicht so aufregen eigentlich eigentlich
eine richtige big brain entscheidungen und die den job war im prinzip sich nett anzuhören
am telefon und die haben immer so eine standard mail geschickt wenn sich einer beschwert hat
und da stand auch auch drin dass der techniker mit hochdruck an der entstörung arbeitet
zwar immer die gleiche mail und vollkommen egal ob der techniker wirklich dran gearbeitet
oder nicht die haben einfach immer die gleiche mail geschickt dass der techniker mit hochdruck
dran arbeitet und das hat geklappt die meisten leute waren zufrieden entstörungs ausrichtest
kackwort ja na ja aber der telekom oder gerade bei vodafone ist ja quasi störung der normal
von manchen bereichen weißt du warum ich das mache was mal auf aufrufzeichen eins acht
bin ich eingeloggt habe ich erklärt warum ich das mache das habe ich mir irgendwann
mal angewöhnt und jetzt krieg ich nicht mehr los ich will ich will ich will es auch ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht los kriegen ich finde das finde das es ist nichts was mich jetzt belastet
ja so machen wir kurz die ganzen chinesen seiten auf also ich habe zwar in titel geschrieben
china aber wir werden wahrscheinlich auch einiges bei amazon kaufen aber jetzt nachdem
das schiff weg ist kann durchaus sein dass wir wieder was bei china bestellen wo kommt
man nicht die steuerung bei vodafone in letzter zeit ich habe keine ahnung ich weiß ich
wenn ich arbeite nicht bei vodafone und man kriegt das ich mache mal werbung von aliexpress
immer ganz schnell zu man kriegt das ja nicht so mit also ich weiß es nicht keine ahnung
haben wir hier banggood haben wir dark reader aus dark reader sieht so man muss ja einmal
wisst ihr was mich bei diesen china seiten dh geld ist auch so ein ding wisst ihr was
mich bei diesen china seiten immer hardcore verwirrt glaube ich hab das schon fünf die
seiten sehen einfach fucking gleich aus gibt es irgendwie das ministerium für webdesign
auch in china die alle die alle china china chinesen shops mal guckt euch mal die seiten
an das sind unterschiedliche leden aber die sehen alle gleich aus mehr oder weniger also
die ähnlichkeit ist nicht zu leugnen oder warum kriege ich mittels ohne wäsche empfohlen
flash deals moment ist es flashdienst weil die am flaschen ist oder oder weil es so
schnell vorbeigeht wo kathos beide wei kein photoshop bild wieder null ja könnt ihr euch
noch an das bild erinnern wo der bauch nicht richtig auf das auf die hose gepasst hat
bei dem einen express bild da hatten wir doch mal ein bild da wurden auch da wurde auch
unterwäsche gezeigt und der bauch hat überhaupt nicht zur hose gepasst das war richtig schlecht
zusammen photoshop nein die sind nicht alle alibaba das sind unterschiedliche das sind
unterschiedliche sachen und es gibt es gibt da noch mehr china shops aber die sehen alle
gleich aus die haben die als hätten die als hätten die ein offiziellen staats web designer
oder so oder wie auch was auch immer die chinesen da so haben und der macht einfach für alle
shops die web sein wie we use cookies als würde euch das in china interessieren ok
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt datenschutz disclaimer bei banggood was steht da so drin seite nicht
gefunden oder was ok standard text thanks for submitting feedback ich habe kein feedback
submitted ich glaube es geht einfach schlicht und nicht ok wir informieren jetzt erstmal
über corona bei banggood was sonst beste stelle ok nicht so viel oder doch will my package
have kovid jaja ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt wenn die dinge das infiziert
bevor sie es rausschicken die chinesen fabrik in shenzhen die desinfizieren man paket ganz
bestimmt vorher jaja in china gibt es kein kovid alles klar das ist ja auch immer das
ist ja so die sache die chinesen melden einfach keine zahlen mehr und sagen dann ja wir haben
nix mehr es ist weg wenn wir was hätten wir denn ihr seht es doch an den zahlen wir haben
nix mehr so also das ist das ist genau das gleiche wieder ein ce zeichen drauf ist und
so was das ist auch so ein ding wobei das kann man glaube ich selbst drauf drücken
ehe gleich china export was das eigentlich für eine pedo bär werbung hier für mama
und die kleinen die kleinen kriegen eine drohne wo sie dann beim nachbar über den zahn gucken
können und mama kriegt ein kinderwerk oder wie also gucken wir mal kurz ich brauch nix
wahnsinnig dringend das aber es gibt so ein paar sachen da wollte ich schon die ganze
zeit mal nachgucken aber jetzt können wir einfach im stream machen ich muss mal kurz
schauen wo ich mein dokument habe ah hier ok wunderbar heute ich bin immer noch am überlegen
was mit meiner usb machen ich habe ja ich habe ja seit ein paar jahren so eine so eine
ist einmal power so ein teil hier glaube irgendwie so ein teil ja so ein teil habe ich ja seit
zwei jahren und die batterie ist kaputt mein komplettes rack ist kaputt gegangen wäre
wegen der batterie ich bin immer noch am überlegen soll ich einfach die usb komplett rauskicken
und sagen moment und sagen und sagen oder soll ich die batterie tauschen ich bin da
hin und her gerissen weil das ding geht wieder kaputt in zwei jahren und das ganze rack geht
aus ja optimaler produktname wer kommt da nicht drauf cp or 600 er m1u rack mount kommt
eigentlich noch dabei hier er m1u ja alles klar also ich tendiere aktuell dazu ich lasse
die im rack einfach als beschwerung unten drinnen und das war es und ich oder ich hole
mir eine andere usb die nicht kaputt geht wenn die batterie kaputt ist weil ich sollte ich
würde ja eigentlich von der usb erwarten dass wenn strom da ist und die batterie kaputt
ist dass es einfach weiter geht das ist ja noch nicht meine online usb wo alles durch
die batterie geht dachte ich zumindest aber anscheinend doch keine ahnung die haben die
chinesen haben corona besser unter kontrolle als wir ja kann ich mir vorstellen die chinesen
haben ja prinzipiell da auch wenig probleme mit wenn es um beschränkungen geht im zweifelsfall
sagen die einfach jeder den wir auf der straße erwischen erwischen wird erschossen easy oder
geht keiner mehr raus ich weiß nicht ob ich weiß nicht wie sie was wirklich machen ja
aber die für die anderen prinzip kein problem damit das ist das geile das ist das geile
wo so dieses krankenhaus gebaut hat er kennt ihr dieses bild kennt dieses bild china krankenhaus
bagger dieses genau das da das ist auch so richtig geiles mag chinesen marketing bild
was genau machen diese bagger da eigentlich jetzt sagt mir nicht baggern ich ich bezweifle
dass man effektiv baggern kann mit 50 bagger auf diesem grundstück zumal da gar keine
löcher sind richtig die haben einfach die bagger für das foto da hinten für das hinten
für das da hinten du kannst da nicht das geht doch gar nicht effektiv damit da muss
ein lkw hin die sachen abtransportieren und sonst was kannst du voll knicken das ist einfach
so ein marketing bild von den chinesen so nach dem motto nehmt man ein felt stellt 50 bagger
drauf wir fotografieren das dann mit einer drohne
was ist gelb und kann nicht schwimmen oder gibt es einiges so ein dhl auto zum beispiel
wo wir gerade wo wir gerade bei absolut unwitzigen witzen sind was ist blau und steht am kopierer
der praktif fand es gibt so unglaublich viel unlustige sachen richtig feins richtig schlecht
so ja genau das denke ich mir auch leonidas weil eigentlich ist es eine offline usb und
die sollte eigentlich weiter funktionen auch wenn die batterie kaputt ist mein problem
ist ich finde dazu überhaupt keine information wenn da irgendwo stehen würde so nach dem
motto batterie hält drei jahre aber so lang strom da ist bleibt das weg weiterhin an
wird das ding kaufen am besten noch in reckbauweise geht auch ohne ich kann auch unten einfachen
ein stein quasi in usv form reinlegen ins rack ist auch ok wer bei amazon kauft schade
der deutschen wirtschaft juckt mich nicht ich kaufe da wo es für mich am einfachsten
ist und außerdem kaufen wir in china also wenn wir in china kaufen schaden wird garantiert
nicht der deutschen wirtschaft weil die sachen die wir da kaufen die gibt es hier gar nicht
ja also wie gesagt dieses bild ist halt ultra geil mit den baggern hier einfach random random
rum baggern so was ich sagen wollte bei den chinesen die haben halt die haben halt da überhaupt
keine probleme mit na was also ich frage mich halt ernsthaft stellt euch mal vor die chinesen
sind hier am baggern wie verrückt und und der oberbauminister hat gesagt in zehn tagen
müsst ihr fertig sein sonst werdet ihr alle erschossen oder keine ahnung was die so sagen
ja stellt euch mal vor da fällt einer von bagger jetzt frage ich mich ziehen die den
aus der krube raus oder schütten die krube einfach zu weil es schneller geht bin ich
dann nicht so sicher wahrscheinlich wird er verbundet wahrscheinlich wird er verbundet
und dann kriegt die familie noch irgendwie irgendwie den brief dass der vater ehrenhaft
für für das vaterland sein leben gelassen hat und der bagger rollt drüber oder so bei
max in china immer jeder ok vielleicht wirst auch geköpft oder so wobei nie geköpft ist
er ist es nicht china ich glaube ich glaube die chinesen erschießen die eher leute geköpft
wirst glaube ich eher so in so im nahen osten irgendwo ich glaube die köpfen noch ganz
gerne leute aber zumindest eine sache sieht man ganz gut an china die haben es mit menschenrechten
nicht so und ich weiß ich bringe den schock jetzt zum 50.000 mal aber deswegen ist java
und c++ auch so beliebt in china guckt euch github repos an ganz viel aus china ist java
oder c++ das wundert mich einfach nicht mehr bei den chinesen ja nur dass die französer
die franzosen das nicht mehr machen also so viel so viel glückliche grills beim shoppen
bei der dh geht
bei strike wie es haben die haben die mittlerweile können wir sind ja nicht mal in der lage
mehr die leute irgendwie ordentlich zu köpfen oder was früher das ist auch nicht mehr das
was es mal war das shit rebo
so das stimmt überhaupt nicht vor 40 jahren leute
das stimmt überhaupt nicht was das ist das ist verkehr die die franzosen die franzot
die letzte das wird das weiß ich zufällig weil da habe ich mein artikel drüber gelesen
jetzt mal hier sinnloser knowledge drop die letzte hinrichtung in frankreich war ungefähr
1900 und da war christopher lee dabei als zuschauer also also sah rumann aus herr der
ringe ja ich meine welche anderen ja was weiß ich welche anderen länder da was was machen
aber in frankreich war die letzte hinrichtung 1900 das weiß ich da habe ich mein artikel
drüber gelesen gelesen wo es um christopher lee ging und christopher lee war quasi auf
den weg in urlaub oder so und die sind dann durch frankreich gefahren und haben dazu
geguckt
würdest du netwerke network equipment preflashed aus china kaufen zum beispiel steckdose und
router was denn so zum beispiel mir fällt gar kein
netwerke equipment ein was aus china kaufen würde ja ok dann dann dann ein bisschen später
nicht um 1900 aber ihr wisst was ich meine
ja also ja das das weiß ich inwieweit das zählt in frankreich weil in der hessischen
verfassung weiß ich ob ihr das wisst aber in der in der hessischen ich glaube ich habe
mich übrigens ein bisschen verschätzt ich glaube zwar nicht um 1900 es war wahrscheinlich
eher um 1900 1930 oder so rum aber in der hessischen in der hessischen verfassung gibt
es angeblich noch die todestrafe aber halt juckt halt kein genau genau tatsächlich
guck mal hier die franzosen die franzosen 1977 hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht bei
den franzosen ich habe gedacht die sind da schon ein bisschen länger nicht mehr auf dem
trip aber eins muss man ja sagen das haben die ja eh perfektioniert die haben es ja quasi
erfunden so so dass das das das köpfen im endeffekt also das das öffentlichkeitswirksame
ja das wurde vor paar jahren aus der hessischen der hessischen verfassung entfernt tatsächlich
ja echt ist es weg ich also ich wusste noch früher in der schule da hat uns das mal lehrer
erzählt dass dass das in der hessischen verfassung noch drin steht aber gut dann ist es erst
letztens irgendwie rausgekommen ja ja das stand ganz lange der hessischen verfassung
drin aber gut nachdem die hessische verfassung wollte ich gerade sagen nachdem die hessische
verfassung in dem fall eh nicht interessiert ist egal aber ist schon so ein bisschen mittelalterlich
so also das wir anfangen einzukaufen ich hätte mal ich habe mal hier an die elektro stelzer
bei uns im an die elektropros ich habe im flur ein moment fast und ich glaube man sieht
es sogar in dem video baustelle moment baustelle da gibt es ein video da gibt es ein video
auf der baustelle real life ich glaube das ist ich meine die elektro champs genau youtube
ist das hier wo ich mit dem fahrstuhl fahr ne aber ich glaube hier sieht man es auch also
naja okay hier war doch im haus gar nichts ich habe doch ein video wo ich den fahrstuhl
von meinem ober zeig so und da sieht man das ganz gut was ich euch fragen muss weil ich
habe so ein leerrohr hier gut was auch immer anscheinend anscheinend
also ich habe einen leerrohr im flur und vielleicht sieht man das hier naja auf hier
hier jetzt wo ich raus gehe machs bisschen die kamera rechts ich hätte mal die kamera
ein bisschen schwenken können das brauche ich jetzt sieben jahre später also hier habe
ich ein leerrohr in der wand so quasi hier dahinter hier ist leerrohr in der wand und
du glaubst das zweite video das ist doch das zweite video ach moment moment ich hab doch
das bild mit den genau das bild mit mit den mit den bildern vom ober der so viel nackige
medels gemalt hat muss aufpassen das kann ich jetzt hier im extrem nicht zeigen aber
hier beste kamera führung aller zeiten so hier neben leute hier habe ich ein leerrohr
hier so da wo da wo es karteert das bild hier habe ich ein leerrohr so und das leerrohr
geht vom keller erster erdgeschoss erster stock und ich würde gern im im flur dort wo das
leerrohr ist jeweils noch steckdosen an die wand machen wobei es mussten gar keine steckdosen
an die wand sein halt stecker wie mache ich das am besten also ich will nicht am verteilerschrank
was machen weil da traue ich mich nicht und es soll gefälligst elektriker machen aber
wie mache ich das am besten ich meine ich könnte doch theoretisch unten im keller einfach
in den steckdosen ein kabel einstecken und dann im erd dann das kabel also erstmal natürlich
nicht raus machen und dann einfach das kabel also natürlich insoliert das kabel kein offenes
kabel einfach das kabel durch den leerkanal schieben raus machen im erdgeschoss hochschieben
raus machen im ersten stock dann dort nen stecker dran machen oder nen oder ne oder
so ne bukse halt und dann unten in den stecker in die steckdose stecken
neben dem rohr die wand aufstellen ne das will ich nicht machen man wird eigentlich
mal wieder gestellts wir stellts noch immer was was soll denn gestellts werden ja ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher gibt es denn gibt es denn steckdosen nicht für die wand einfach
so normale steckdosen so so welche wo man einfach nen kabel rein macht das ordentlich
fest macht dass es nicht rausgehen kann also wo man nen kabel rein reinschraubt und dann
hinten irgendwie ein bisschen zugrenzlastung dran und auf das muss noch weder auf noch
unter das kann meinetwegen auch an der wand baumeln das ist mir egal ich will da einfach
nen stecker aber ich weiß nicht nach was ich suchen muss das kann da auch raus baumeln
aus der wand das ist mir egal ich brauche einfach nen stecker der chat weiß wieder
bescheid ja sowas im endeffekt genau genau sowas da genau das was der chat gerade gepost
hat sowas da aber erstmal schön hier erstmal hier richtig schön ref links gespammt excellent
sowas da in der richtung genau wobei das halt echt ein bisschen pence champig aussieht
oder wie funsten das da macht man hinten das kabel rein schraubts rein und machts
noch mal extra fest dass es nicht raus kann oder ap-gehäuse aufputzgehäuse mit abdeckrahmen
aha aha der chat ist wieder richtig high IQ zeig mal hoch zeig mal her und wie soll
das jetzt funktionieren und wie macht man das wie macht man das an die wand schrauben
durch oder klebt man das oder na kleben kann ja schlecht sein oder
wie schrauben sie zu drehlöcher aah ach so also sprich man macht schrauben hin hier
durch dann quasi so lass mal so ein bisschen rum ach so ok ja gut das ist ein steck kein
schlechter so und ich würde ich würde es halt so machen weil aktuell ist es halt also
normalerweise würde ich sagen hier elektriker schließ mir das mal unten im verteilerkasten
an und dann ist gut aber aktuell ist unglaublich schwer elektrikertermin zu bekommen deswegen
würde ich die nupe variante machen einfach hier steckdosen an die wand kabel nehmen kabel
durch das leer rausschieben und unten einfach in eine steckdose stecken ich habe unten im
keller noch genug freie steckdosen nehme ich einfach das kabel wenn es aus dem lehr aus
dem aus dem aus dem kanal kommt steck ich so in die steckdose rein
ne ne am schalt am schaltschrank mache ich nichts da ich zu viel schiss vor ok das ist
aber eine gute idee chat muss ich zugeben da habt ihr mich mal auf eine idee gebracht
das können wir machen ja also wenn schon ich würde eh schon mal am liebsten würde ich
aber ganz ohne klemmen dazwischen machen sondern dass man das halt und ich denke mal das ist
da auch so wenn man das da rein steckt also ich denke mal man wird das man wird das ziemlich
fest machen können da drinnen wobei ja gut ich brauche da noch die passende steckdose
dazu oder also hier kommen die eigentlich steckdosen dann rein also da braucht man gar
keine klemme ich würde ich würde jetzt eine reinschrauben und wahrscheinlich schraubst
du es fest und und hinten hast du irgendwie so eine art zugentlastung dran und dann ist
wahrscheinlich prompt fest das ding das könnte man machen ja
gut dass wir das geklärt haben by the way ich habe vorhin auf amazon gesehen was war
das eine steckdose mit von kick ne moment wie ich sehr hersteller die angeblich flashbar
ist da habe ich überlegt das müsste man eigentlich gerade mal wieder ausprobieren
einen hersteller mit k am anfang das ist alles der gleiche krab und ich habe schon eigentlich
genug steckdose das ist so das ist so ein kokona ding das ist was das geht nur das
geht nur bei den amis das geht einfach mal wieder nur bei den amis schrauben schneide
man noch in die wand macht es mal viel spaß hast du mitbekommen dass nvidia pci passt
trufe ihre konsumer gpu ist jetzt zulässt du konntest du konntest grafikkarten schon
immer pcu pci passt tru machen ich habe sogar mal ich habe sogar mal 90 80 ti pci passt
truht in windows vm kvm oder linux das ging die ganze zeit schon ach ja stimmt ich erinnere
mich ich glaube man musste die doch ich weiß doch doch das stimmt das stimmt das ging nicht
so einfach man musste man musste die pci express id irgendwie überschreiben oder so was genau
genau genau so was muss man du musstest irgendwie überschreiben dass das nicht erkennt dass
du dass du kvm bist aber zwar easy zwar ein konfig eintrag und es hat funktioniert kein
ding ja das ist halt das ist halt typische ami pappwand das kannst du vergessen ne ne
980 ti keine 90 80 ti 980 ti so also gut ihr habt mir schon mal geholfen mit den meinst
du tp link steckdosen nein ich mein irgendein hersteller mit k das habe ich vorhin als ich
auf dem klo gesessen habe auf dem smartphone gesehen moment ich kann doch moment ich gucke
einfach mal kurz hier auf die amazon app da steht doch immer history drinne browser history
bringt amazon empfiehlt mir gerade ne oui ja previously viewed kexen kexen heißt der hersteller
kexen alter so und da habe ich in den kommentaren gelesen man kann angeblich flaschen aber
da stand habe ich nicht gesehen von her kak wait
äh war das nicht die flash what the fuck wie wie kam man in a hier flash
bin ich jetzt total hängen geblieben waren die das nicht ich habe vorhin auf dem klo
gesessen und habe bei amazon die app mal aufgemacht habe steckdosen empfohlen bekommen habe in
die kommentare geguckt da stand drinne irgendwie erfolgreich mit das motor geflasht leonidas
da sind wir wollte ich gerade danach gucken aber die sind anscheinend nicht sehr merkwürdig
das muss die gewesen sein nicht mehr angeguckt dabei die war noch in der history also vielleicht
war das auch nicht die die ich jetzt gefunden habe brain lag richtig brain lag ich habe
ja glücklicherweise davon auch das pack bekommen was man flaschen konnte ich meine man kann
die alle was zum teufel machen die da was waren die chinesen da schon wieder
versuche gerade den sinn zu erkennen in dem was die chinesen da treiben wieder die wollen
glaube ich einfach nur zeigen wie geil das ist dass ihre steckdosen so klein sind und
da reinpassen genau die konnte man nämlich noch flaschen als ich die gekauft habe das
geht mittlerweile nicht mehr so richtig ja leider geht vieles nicht mehr vieles nicht
mehr mit neuem firmware tut das motor geht nicht ja also man kann die dinge aufschrauben
man kann die dinge aufschrauben und flaschen das haben wir auch schon im stream gemacht
ich habe da aber ehrlich gesagt mal ich muss mal kurz licht über den home assistant einschalten
aber ich habe da ehrlich gesagt gar kein gar kein bock drauf die alle aufzuschrauben
kann flaschen
da ist no obvious way to open this klar dazu für die dinger gibt sogar eine anleitung
im internet wie man die wie man die aufschraubt und flascht da wurde ich übrigens geflammt
auf twitter weil ich geschrieben habe welcher chineser hat sich das ausgedacht habe ich
da geschrieben oder wurde ich geflammt weil ich geschrieben habe das hätte sich ein
chineser ausgedacht oder es geht ja gar nicht ich kann auch nicht einfach assuming dass
eine steckdose aus china von einem chineser gebaut wurde ok ich meine vielleicht war es
auch irgendein brasilianer im exil oder so ich würde halt einfach mal behaupten die
chance dass es ein chineser war sind relativ hoch weil es ali express steckdosen sind
country assumed
ja die leute haben mittlerweile echt einen kompletten schaden was das thema angeht
richtig triggert richtig triggert
deine kammer nicht aufschrauben die sind gesteckt ja ja meine war auch gesteckt und zwar ist
die plug du hast hast du die hier das ist die die ich eben bei amazon gezeigt habe da
sind die hier die sind nicht geschraubt die sind gesteckt aber es gibt eine anleitung
wie du die flaschen kannst danach habe ich das auch gemacht bei denen wo das nicht über
w lang ging du musst die aufhebeln allerdings ist das echt ganz schönes gefuddelt bis
du die auf hast du kannst die aufhebeln an der seite ich hatte irgendwann keinen bock
mehr ich habe einfach einen kleinen schraubenzieher
genommen und habe den rein gehauen mit einem hammer auf der einen seite so ein stück bis
ich drunter war und dann habe ich es rausgehebelt das heißt alle alle alle steckt also alle
dieser steckdosen die ich jetzt geflasht habe die haben jetzt eine beule an der seite weil
ich die auch weil ich die aufgemacht habe an der stelle aber ich habe einfach heißkleber
oben rings rum dann rein gefüllt und wieder zugemacht scheiß drauf genau und das flaschen
ging folgendermaßen du das sah exakt so aus wie hier bei dem typ auf dem bild du musstest
du musstest hier dein serial flasher musstest du anlöten ground und gpio 0 verbinden flasher
dran und immer dran denken wenn man den flasher anschließt rx und tx vertauschen also tx
auf rx und und rx auf tx vom flasher man funktioniert aber schön ist es nicht was
macht eigentlich tuja convert auf github gibt es da mittlerweile schon neue sachen hallo
was ist denn mit dem dark reader los warum ist der warum ist der dark reader so so lahm
da müssen wir jetzt gerade mal kurz auf shithub gucken ob es da engeln slow haben wir es
jetzt wieder einschalten ohne dass wir hier blind werden
slo slo slo confirmed und firefox slo wie warum ist das
klaus
bixxer das ist bestes also ich finde ich weiß nicht wie findet ihr bixxer als mekko
als name die anderen fand ich cooler bixxer erinnert mich ihr okay ich weiß gar nicht
gerade mich das erinnert gefällt mir aber nicht gut
warum schließen die das ticket das ding ist das ding ist broken das ding ist broken gerade
genau github.com erzählt freezing a lot firefox die haben bestimmt doch heimlich an die chinesen
verkauft was für ein ding
nein ich glaube nicht dass dark reader eine chinesen verkauft ist
okay
vielleicht gibt es bald eine neue version dass das ganze gefixt wird weil ohne dark reader
ist auch doof aber mit dark reader wenn die seiten nicht laden sagt auch richtig
okay es gibt eine neue version vielleicht unterstützen die ein bisschen mehr
ne ne ne ne ne ne keine chance leute man kann man kann die sachen nicht mehr ordentlich
flaschen mit der neueren firmware das sagt man kann hier nur noch aufschrauben was was
auf einen schlag ganz viele china steckdosen komplett useless macht ich meine dann kann
ich mir auch direkt dann kann ich mir auch direkt shelly steckdosen kaufen die kostet
ein bisschen mehr sowas hier zum beispiel
kann ich mir auch direkt shelly steckdosen kaufen die kosten zwar mehr aber die sind
von haus aus flashbar und kommen schon mit guter firme hatten wir nicht letztens mal
auf aliexpress geguckt die steckdosen die mit das motor ausgeliefert werden da wollte
ich immer gucken
ja habe ich doch letztens wir hatten das doch schon mal hier
die ersten für 34 nacht das sind aber gar keine gosund oder
was hast du gesehen was wurde geleakt wieder was wurde geleakt hier kann eigentlich nichts
geleakt werden das motor hier also
näher das von 2019
tuja convert funktioniert 19 der erste ok
excellent excellent ok nice nice
ja gesund sind sie erst nach corona pains jam joke wieder
wie kann man amazon auf dark mode umstellen mit einem addon
aber da hat es hat gerade probleme es ist ein wenig knifflig
die platine sieht genauso aus wie platinen fotos von blitzwolf
ok der hat angelötet mit tuja convert ging nicht tuja convert funktioniert 19 der erste
ok leute ich bestell mir da mal testweise was
ich bestell mir einfach testweise was guck ob es geht ihr wisst ich bin ein ich lasse
mich immer debaten von so einem kram ich habe davon genug ich habe mehr als genug steckdosen
ich brauche das eigentlich nicht
hat das ein vierer pack das ist halt das ist halt schon kummer wenn ihr euch überlegt
so ein jelly plug so ein jelly plug kostet im shop
16 58 das heißt ich kriege hier für den preis von zwei kriege ich hier halt vier stück
schon mal nicht verkehrt
funktioniert einwandfrei ok
wie oft hast du probleme mit zoll mit aliexpress gar nicht weil die chinesen das richtig machen
die amis kriegen sie immer nicht hin beziehungsweise zoll leipzig kriegt sich hin die chinesen
haben da kein problem die chinesen schicken entweder über spanien niederlande oder oder
sonst wie oder direkt aus dem eu wahren lager die die china dinger landen nicht im zoll
so das motor wie wie hieß denn die diese die firma die vorgeflasht das motor steckdosen
macht
ihr wollt ich noch vorhin was zu sagen
hast du schon gehört dass hessen dass hessen kein microsoft teams mehr benutzen ja das
habe ich gehört was ich ganz grausam finde ist dass sie ihr eigenes portal machen wollen
es ist ja nicht so als gibt es nicht schon zigtausend volk und und chat sachten sachen
nacks was nutzt du für dein ganzes mqtt zeugs home assistant home assistant und den den
eingebauten container mqtt container
ja
ich probiere das mal
aliexpress oder war das auf bengot wo es das gab die tasmotor vor preflasht
aliexpress tasmotor preflasht
da gab es die dinger preflasht tasmotor
in china
viererpack siehste da kostet der kram schon gleich mal mehr
hat irgendjemand eine glorreiche idee warum ich nix finde wenn ich nach tasmotor suche
bei aliexpress
obwohl obwohl es hier im titel drin steht
das ist alles wlan
also ich bestell leute ihr wisst ich bin so ein steckdosen flasher ich flashe gerne
steckdosen wenn der chat sagt ich jetzt ist die große frage dem chat vertrauen oder nicht
dem chat vertrauen oder im chat nicht vertrauen ist jetzt die frage
ich bestell die jetzt einfach und dann teste ich mal ob das ob das klappt
chat lügt
34 euro haben die anderen nicht auch so viel gekostet
die anderen haben 44 euro gekostet
und versandt bei amazon kosten kein versand
angeblich kann man ihn noch flaschen ok
hat jemand eine sinnvolle erklärung dafür warum die chinesen überhaupt neue firmware
versionen benutzen
warum man das nicht mehr flaschen kann
weil ich glaube die
den geht es doch einfach nur darum viel zu verkaufen
den kann es doch egal sein ob die leute die sache flaschen oder nicht
ich meine es kaufen viele leute einfach nicht mehr dann dadurch also ich kauf mir die nicht
flaschen kann
ich glaube eher dass es nicht am hersteller liegt sondern an den den distributor leuten
die wollen dass man ihren scheiß verwendet und die daten sammeln können
der hersteller der dinger selbst den ist das wahrscheinlich relativ egal
du hast eine gos und sp1 jammer nur einen knopf statt den zwei usb ports
ja wie geht es usb ports
achso hier
du meinst die da du meinst die haben diese da haben bei dir kein usb port sondern nur
ein knopf
wie da steht explizit usb dabei wenn es kein usb hat dann
das ist sp1 2 ja
aber die haben kein an und aus knopf
die lassen sich oder flaschen ok das ist nice
achso das ist bloß nicht abgebildet der knopf
mehr es ist ja auch total uninteressant die steckdose mal so abzubilden dass man sie sieht
ne
louis vitor hat auch was was sp1 2 heißt
achtung gos und achtung
boah ey warum painz jam ich bin blind flashbang oder gibt's verschiedene von
ok das ist wie man das flash das ist mir ich will ich ja nicht ich will über ota flaschen
hä hier steht jetzt dass die schon eine weile nicht mehr ota flaschbar sind what the fuck
monka
da gibt's davon mal ein bild wie sieht das schalter oben aus
aber gibt es von dieser steckdose einfach kein bild von oben wo das schalter ist ach
hier
ne hier passt schon aber es geht um millimeter bei amazon schreiben sie in der bewertung
auch dass das hier hier schreiben manche aber wenn das das falsche
hier schreiben die leute nämlich dass es angeblich noch geht januar 2021
ich glaube es ist einfach ein bisschen glück was man noch flaschen kann und was nicht
das ist doch genau die gleiche
da sind die ohne usb jetzt oder wie
aber ich finde die mit usb viel geiler leute ich weiß ja was scheiß drauf bamm ich probiere
das jetzt aus und wenn ich mache im stream auf und und und löten dran und flaschen die
easy
ich habe hier alles noch im basket drin
ach so vom letzten mal ok kann ich alles wieder raus machen
habe ich habe ich habe ich doch alles schon habe ich alles schon gekauft
habe ich alles schon
ich lock mich ja hier nicht ein und bestell das
ich probiere das wir probieren das im stream aus leute wir probieren das im stream aus
ob sie flaschen flaschen flaschen lassen und wenn ich wird aufgeschraubt
ihr wisst wie pfleglich die steckdosen behandelt beim aufschrauben
da wird dann rumgerobbt und sonst wie und das letzte mal hat mich die steckdose ja
massif jebaited mit hintenrum aufgebrochen und dann festgestellt vorne gibt's schrauben
für
ich die jebaited jebaited
copper miller eh hiller hiller danke schön für die 2 2 monate subs
ich muss mal gucken dass ich keine subs übersehen habe
tja amazon bewertungen lesen tas motorseiten gucken und hoffen so wirklich 100 prozentig
ist da leider nix
sonics hat subscrib vor 41 minuten sorry habe ich übersehen 2 monate dankeschön für
den sub
für welches anwendungsgebiet nur zu wlan steckdosen zum beispiel dass man 3d drucke
ein und ausschalten kann dass ich den heizlüfter im klo ein und ausschalten kann dass ich
den staubsauger unten wenn er am aufladen ist automatisch ausschalten kann wenn er
voll ist das übrigens ein coolen einsatzgebiet für steckdosen die gucken können was da
gerade dran hängt also diese verbrauchsanzeige haben da kannst du nämlich einfach sagen
wenn also ist ja meistens so wenn geräte aufladen die die fangen ein bisschen langsam
an dann laden sie ein bisschen stärker und am ende geht's wieder runter und ich hab gesagt
sobald das was an der steckdose dran ist unter vier watt ist dann ausschalten also wenn das
länger als fünf minuten unter vier watt ist dann ausschalten weil dann ist der staubsauger
voll geladen ja für so sachen verwende ich das das ist äußerst praktisch und ich kann
das ding auch noch aus dem bett oder so ausschalten wenn ich sage ah mist habe ich vergessen
für alles mögliche also hast du heizkörper thermostat im ansatz ja habe ich aber erst
seit neuestem erst seit so weiß nicht vier fünf monaten ich hatte ich hatte am anfang
sich die thermostate und die haben echt hardcore gesagt ich habe jetzt fritz deckt die rote
pest aus berlin hängt bei mir jetzt sind die eigentlich nicht rot fritz box ist auch
rot hängt bei mir jetzt an der heizung und ich muss sagen die dinger machen einen deutlich
besseren also die sind auch dort die sind auch viel teurer und eigentlich auch viel
zu unsinnig teuer ja aber die machen einen viel besseren eindruck die sind gut verarbeitet
die funktionieren das einzig dumme an denen ist dass die bis zu 15 minuten brauchen können
bis die ihre werte abgerufen haben was jetzt für eine automatische heizungssteuerung jetzt
nicht so problematisch ist weil du regelt die temperatur so über den tag weg und ob
das jetzt 15 minuten früher oder später das macht jetzt so aber wenn man beispielsweise
sagt hey ich will jetzt keine ahnung wir setzen uns jetzt gleich ins wohnzimmer abendessen
oder so und ich drücke dann im home assistant auf jetzt jetzt heizung im wohnzimmer anmachen
dann ist es ein bisschen doof dass es teilweise bis zu 15 minuten dauern kann bis sie wirklich
angehen was auch kein wirklich richtig großes problem ist weil du kannst einfach auf den
knopf drücken dann holst du sich das sofort hast du fenster sensoren ja habe ich habe
ich mir aber aliexpress gekauft ich kann euch mal was zeigen in der hoffnung ich liege nicht
wieder was fenster sensors
nee kann ich euch nicht zeigen das ist auf der startseite da liege ich da liege ich
die haltestelle von der ich fahre aber habe ich ich habe mal ich habe mal bei bengut für
unter zehn euro das stück ich kaufe die ich kaufe so sachen eigentlich immer ganz gerne
wenn sie unter zehn dollar das stück sind mal ein riesen pack gekauft weil die weil
die das war irgendwie bengut jubiläum sale vom hersteller und sonst wie die kostet normalerweise
25 dollar oder so und das war dann unter zehn da habe ich gleich ein riesen pack gekauft
und ich habe immer noch eine kiste voll mit acht stück oder so kannst du opera als browser
empfehlen nein mittlerweile nicht mehr weiß ich auch zu wenig zu ich weiß nur dass opera
jetzt den chinesen gehört den china chinesen so als erster bestellt bei wo ich gerade dabei
bin wo einer gefragt hat thermostate
sando ich wollte nichts tatsächlich mal versuchen im video zu machen und euch so viel liege
brave browser habe ich ausprobieren habe ich auch kein anwendungszweck mehr für wozu
einzig gute ist kann er mittlerweile youtube im background plane auf auf ios
jup das macht aber sich wie und sieben elf und wählen heute auch schon ohne internet laufen
das problem sind die hersteller die wollen dass man sich zu irgendeinem web service verbindet
dass man seine heizung anmachen kann aber die können mich mal am arsch lecken so was verwende
ich nicht ich sehe es nicht ein dass man internet funktionieren muss und der cloud anbieter
funktionieren muss dass meine heizung anschalten kann stopp geht los was ich mir zum testen
kaufen wollte ist ein bluetooth ich kann einmal schreiben bluetooth das teil just for fun just
for fun ich wollte mir das teil kaufen und guck mal wie viel kosten der hier gerade moment
meint lull just for fun weil das kann man custom firmen flaschen und ihr wisst ich stehe
auf alles was man custom firmen flaschen kann die kann man flaschen ja was machen die eigentlich
kann man dort irgendwas einstellen oder ist das eine reine anzeige was kann man dann mehr
ich habe keine ahnung bitcoins meinen kannst du darauf guck mal hier ist die custom hier
ist die custom firmen wir für diese dinger alter ist das billig bei bei chinesen da ist
leute ein moment es ist jebait das ist jebait das ist jebait das ist wieder so ein aliexpress
jebaiting die tasche kostet 146 das thermos kart das thermostat kostet 10 euro
richtig jebaited wobei das drei stück sind für 10 das stimmt das stimmt das ist trotzdem
eine ganze ecke billiger als bei aliexpress schwachsinn ist bei aliexpress eine ganze ecke
billiger als bei amazon warte mal 14 durch 4 kostet das eine 3 und das andere ist 10
durch 3 na gut das sind 3,r also das heißt im endeffekt ist sogar der 3er pack billiger
ein bisschen bisschen nicht viel aber bisschen erstmal 30 stück kaufen voraussicht liege
5 der mai ok das vielleicht ein bisschen viel 35 ok gibt es die dinger irgendwo außen ok
china china ok du findest wieder die hälfte nicht bei aliexpress
na was muss ich denn suchen dass ich den kram finde
oh fuck fuck verklickt verklickt verklickt verklickt ja da ach hier unten kommen noch
mehr ok neue version ok 2020 was sind denn der unterschied dazwischen das ist doch alles
das gleich oder
Aber guck mal, hier kosten 3 Stück nur 9 Euro und hier kostet 1 2 Euro, das wird ja immer
billiger.
Das wird ja immer billiger.
WarChamp ist da, alles klar.
Special Line, das sollte man auf jeden Fall machen, dann gibt es auch keine Probleme
mit dem Zoll.
So wir gucken mal kurz, wir gucken mal kurz bei Banggood.
Ah, Sekunde, wo kann ich jetzt zurück?
Thermometer, so und jetzt müssen wir auswählen Schiff aus Deutschland, gibt es nix, ok, aus
Deutschland Schiff nix, oh doch, guck mal, aus Deutschland Schiff, kostenloser Versand,
ah, yes, aha, ach da, ach da wollt ihr jetzt 9,12 Euro haben für, yebaited, ok, siehste,
es lohnt sich bei den Chinesen zu gucken, es lohnt sich einfach bei den Chinesen zu
gucken.
3 Euro 4 bei Amazon 10 Euro, habt ihr das gesehen, Bam, so, Moment, Leute, die haben
sich vertan, der Kram kommt aus China, das ist doch egal, aber das wird von hier geliefert,
Leute, die haben sich vertan, Leute, guck mal, die haben sich vertan, China ist das teuerste,
der Rest ist am billigsten, die haben sich vertan, die wollten 3 Euro aus China und 6
Euro aus Rest schreiben, garantiert, werd ich mit euch, das heißt, jetzt erstmal easy,
easy buy, ah, Moment, der Versand, wait a minute, ah, aha, aha, aha, noch mehr, cheebait,
wo war kostenlos, hier ist kostenloser Versand, aus Spanien, aus China, ships from Germany,
Lieferung bis 2. Mai, hä, das ergibt keinen Sinn, hab ich wirklich Sinn, äh, guck mal,
was es bei Banggood kostet, dann bestell ich mal testweise, die Chinesen haben eine Cheebaited
Abteilung, ja, sieht echt so aus, guck mal, in dem Fall ist Banggood sogar noch ein bisschen
billiger, nee, kostet das gleiche, aber guck mal, der Versand, das ist das bessere Angebot,
da kriegst du 3 Stück aus Tschechien, aus Tschechien, für 88 Cent Germany Priority Mail, Banggood,
ist der Preischamp kaputt, oh, ja, der muss nachher neu starten, der hat wieder den Geist
aufgegeben, okay, da bezahlen wir 4,60 Euro, bei Amazon bezahlen wir für 1,10 Euro, bei
Amazon bezahlen wir 10,90 für, nee, dann bestell ich mal nachher Banggood, nachher Banggood
wird bestellt, muss man gleich mal rüber kopieren, nicht vergessen, Banggood, beste
Seitennahme überhaupt, so, das war nice, also 4,60, 4,60 für 3 Stück, wird der Versand
teurer, guck mal, der Versand wird noch nicht mal teurer, wenn ich mehr nehme, das sind
auch Chinesen, ja, Moment, jetzt wirds ja noch billiger, Sekunde, Moment, die kommen
wahrscheinlich jetzt nur aus China, ne, äh ja, Ships from China, gut, da ist es halt noch
ein Ticken billiger, aber mal drauf geschissen, Banggood Express ist gut, das landet nie mal
im Zoll, warum soll man eigentlich das da nehmen, wenn es länger dauert, man könnte
auch EU Priority Line nehmen, das ist sogar noch besser, das ist die Geschichte, wo es
nie im Zoll landet, ja, das lohnt sich da nicht wirklich, ne, guck mal, hier gibt es
auch wieder welche aus Tschechien, Moment, das sind die, die wir gerade hatten, ne, und
die kommen direkt aus China, ja gut, nee, bestell ich mal nachher ne Packung von, mal
1 bis 3 Business Tastes, who cares, ne, jetzt bezahlen wir die Hälfte, wir bezahlen weniger
als die Hälfte bei Amazon, als bei Amazon, also sind nicht 20 Cent, das sind 5 Euro,
5 Euro pro, pro, genau, und die kann man flashen, habe ich nämlich gefunden, das hier auf
GitHub, Custom Firmware, Moment, Moment, es gibt zwei, zwei verschiedene, warum gibt es
zwei verschiedene Firmwares schon wieder, guck mal, man kann das sogar OTA flashen,
wow, Monkeys, was ist das für eine, Alter, was ist das für eine Seite, ich kriege Augenkrebs,
brauchst du wirklich 3 Stück von, sonst zahlst du nämlich mehr, hä, warum, du meinst,
einer, einer, einer, hä, nee, warum bezahle ich mehr mit, mit, es gibt ja nur drei, das
ist ein Thermometer für Luftfeuchtigkeit und Temperatur, was man halt an die Wand hängen
kann, ehrlich gesagt, ich wollte es einfach mal ausprobieren, nee, ich bestelle keine
einzelnen, ich flash das Ding kaputt und dann ist es im Arsch, und bezahlt, und 15 bezahlt
kann es auch 1 für 10 von Amazon, nee, das ist ja bescheuert, da werden schon nämlich
3 für 15, funktioniert super, warum ist die Website also hässlich, funktioniert die dann
wenigstens, sort, full, def, geht die Seite dann wenigstens, weil die sieht, das sieht
wirklich äußerst painschampig aus, das ist HTML 0.5, was kann das mit Custom Firmware,
ja da bin ich mir auch nicht so ganz sicher, aber erstmal, erstmal das wichtigste ist,
es kann geflasht werden, ok, custom kann geflasht werden, modern browser, ja genau, falls ihr
es nicht wusstet, für diese Seite braucht man einen modernen Browser, ok, Key Features,
jetzt kommt es, Key Features, supports connection using pin code and encrypted bind key beacon,
was bedeutet das überhaupt, man kann 3 verschiedene LCD Screens anzeigen, die sich abwechseln,
das ist ne cooles Feature, reading measurements from flash, boah, man kann ne history auslesen,
improved battery life, ja, Bestellung ist raus, würde ich sagen, so und was schreibt
der andere zu seiner Homepage sozusagen, ok, da schreibt nichts zu Key Features, mich würde
ja mal interessieren, das ist ein ESP32 oder was da drinnen, das heißt, der Kram kann
auch WLAN oder doch nicht, ne, das ist zum abfragen, das ist zum abfragen, das ist zum
abfragen für den ESP32, nicht zum, ach hier ist die Custom Firmware, ja wo ist der Source
von der Custom Firmware, ja, Moment, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz ab, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal
Das war's für heute.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal
Ja, kann man ja machen, wenn man neu baut ist es eh besser, also wenn ich heute nochmal
bauen würde, ich hab damals leider war ich zu low brain, mir da Gedanken drüber zu
machen 2013, würde ich viel mehr Leerrohre machen.
Ne, kann ich auch so, bei Plutus, also es gibt auch Sachen, die kannst du über Plutus
in Homosystem einbinden und die einfachste Variante ist, ich nehm einfach einen ESP32
mit Plutus und frag den Kram ab und schick's an Homosystem, haben wir ja gestern die letzten
zwei Tage genau so was programmiert, bloß dass ich es für Mi Flora Sensors programmiert
hab, die letzten Tage, was denn das für ein Ausgeburt der Hölle, what the fuck, hat er
der Praktikant gelötet oder was, was ist das, what the fuck, die Chinesen schlagen wieder
zu, ach das ist ein ESP32 mit DHTL vom Boden, okay das ist ne komische Konstruktion, das
ist ne ganz ganz merkwürdige Konstruktion, ne, ne, wirklich nett, guck mal du kriegst
sogar, du kriegst sogar nen 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse dabei, ne 200mAh Batterie, das Ding
ist nach zwei Tagen leer, ich muss jetzt einfach mal kurz gucken wie viel Power, oder guck
mal mal, doch Power, Power consumption, das Ding ist, das 200mAh Akku, das hält zwei
Stunden, 60mAh, das ist leer nach ner Woche, trotzdem größere Akku als in nem iPhone Quatsch,
iPhone hat nen deutlich größeren Akku, oder war das ein Choke, den ich nicht kapiert hab,
was hat denn ein iPhone, 6000mAh Akku, ne, das ist iPad wahrscheinlich, 2500, ja, 4000,
und, warum ist das iPhone lost, hält es so viel kürzer als andere Vergleichbare, ich
kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, dass sagen wir mal ein aktuelles Samsung
Android jetzt wirklich nennenswert länger hält als in nem iPhone, würdest du ein Löt
Kit bei den Chinesen bestellen, ne wahrscheinlich nicht, geht doch eigentlich, ja der TS100,
das ist ja tatsächlich cool, aber ich schwöre auf meine Ersa Löt Station, Nano, beste,
ok vielleicht ein bisschen teurer, aber beste Investition für Lötstels gewesen, das Teil,
der so ein TS100 kannst du ja kaufen, die sind ok, Smart Plume, viel zu teuer, aber
das Ding sieht wirklich echt wie die Ausgeburt des Bösen aus hier, da noch mit diesem Schäppen
USB Anschluss, ich glaub das ist gar kein USB, mit dem Schäppen Batterie Anschluss,
heck wait, alter die Dinger sind ja mega hässlich was du dir bei denen kaufen kannst, das sieht
sogar schon ein bisschen anstößig aus ehrlich gesagt das Ding, ok also, sehr gut, also haben
wir schon zwei Sachen am Start, nehm ich die Steckdosen und das Thermometer, Leute meine
Katze frisst die letzten zwei Tage wie verrückt, ich muss Katzenfutter bestellen fällt mir
gerade auf und meine Katze steht extrem auf das hier, Huhn und Lachs, Huhn, Chicken und
Lachs beste, da steht die unglaublich drauf, das findet die nice und die frisst seit zwei
Tagen, ey, die hört gar nicht mal auf zu fressen, ja, meine passt da nicht mehr drauf, doch
ne meine ist ja klein, da ist hier so in der Mitte irgendwo, ja da muss ich auf jeden Fall
wieder ne Packung bestellen, am besten gleich die große, One Time Purchase, Katzenfutter
beste, normalerweise kann man 400 Gramm oder 2 Kilo auswählen, wo ist das hier, 2 Gramm
sind das, ja ganz bestimmt, wo kann ich denn das aus, ach 2 Kilo sind das hier, ja 2 Kilo
ist gut Bam, Pepo Fett für die Katz, Yam Yam Cat Food, Yam Yam, Yam Yam klingt wie
so ein Instantrahmen, wie so Instantrahmen, japanische Instantrahmen, Yam Yam, Subscription
für Katzenfutter, ja das ist Amazon die versuchen haben das immer anzudrehen, ok gut haben wir
das wichtigste schonmal geklärt, so jetzt können wir nochmal zu ein paar anderen Sachen kommen,
ich brauche noch nen USB Hub, allerdings, ich weiß nicht ob es sowas gibt, nen USB Hub
mit möglichst langem Kabel, also ich würde gerne hier bei mir an die Tür, bei mir an
der Tür hängt ne Steckdose mit, also ne schaltbare Steckdose mit zwei USB Steckern dran, aber
ich würde gerne USB Geräte ein paar auf den Schrank legen und da bräuchte ich so, würd
man sagen zwei bis drei Meter USB Kabel am USB Hub, ob es sowas gibt, nen USB Hub mit
3 Meter USB Kabel, ich mein wir könnten ne Verlängerung nehmen ja, einfach Wireless USB
Kabel, ah yes, der Keksen, schau wieder der Keksen, warum ist das so teuer, warum kostet
das, fuck, 65 Euro für nen USB Hub, ist das vergoldet innen drin von Amazon oder was,
oder ist das auch noch so ein komischer Kokona Stecker, nee keine Festplatten auf dem Schrank,
warum ist der so teuer, aber das ist ein langes Kabel, weil man ein x-beliebiges Kabel nehmen
kann, ah man kann das, Moment, ich brauch ja den USB, ich brauch ja das Ding nur, Moment,
ich bin ja eigentlich doof, ich brauch kein USB Hub, ich brauch ja eigentlich nur den
Strom vom USB, ich brauch ja nur den Strom vom USB, ich brauch gar keinen, weil die Geräte
selbst sind Wireless, ich brauch ja gar keine Daten oder sonst wie, also im Prinzip einfach,
ich bräuchte einfach nur nen, ach nee Schwachsinn, ich brauch schon nen USB Kabel, weil ich
hab ja da keinen Stecker, das ist ja der Sinn dahinter gewesen, ich hab ja gar keinen Anschluss
für das Netzteil da, ich will ja eigentlich nen USB Port der nur über USB geht, aber
das geht wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ne, wenn ich nen USB, das ist ja eigentlich, wenn
ich nen USB Hub anschließe an nen USB Port zum Strom versorgen, dann ist das ja limitiert
auf das, was so ein Einzelner kann, ne, also sprich, hier steht was drauf von 5V, 2A, das
heißt, damit werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr als, als sagen wir mal, 3 Geräte irgendwie
sind nicht betreiben können, Anker Powerspeed, was für ein Ding, Anker Powerspeed, aha,
ach, nimmt er 2 USB Ports oder was, Anker Power Ports, Speed 5, beschließt man das an,
ne, ne, ne, ne, beschließt man das an, das kommt, das kommt nicht in USB, ne, das ist,
das kommt an die Steckdose, ah ne, dann, ja, dann muss ich mir das weiter Gedanken machen,
wisst ihr was ich bräuchte, ich bräuchte nen USB Port, nen USB Hub, der nur mit USB Stecker
geht und dafür mit 2, ich will einen der nur vom USB Port geht, weil ich hab ja keinen
Stecker, ich mein, ich hab nen Stecker, aber den brauch ich für was anderes, ah, das glaub
ich, ist keine so gute Idee, was ist das, Monka, ah, das oben sind Daten und unten ist
nur Charge, aber meine Steckdose hat kein USB C, ne, und ich spreide, das ist doch was
ganz anderes, aber die übertreiben es hier ganz schön mit Stecker, oder, Flup, Flup,
Flup, Flup, Flup, 12V, 3A, ja klar, ich war es nicht genau, ich war es nicht genau,
ich hab nur das PC Port am PC, ja, aber das bringt mir ja nichts, ich will das ja an die
Steckdose an der Tür machen, die hat nur diesen normalen, das sieht aus wie so ein billig
von Aliexpress, ist es wahrscheinlich auch, Enter, ah, Müll brauchen wir nicht, ne, da
muss man noch mal Gedanken drüber machen, ich glaub, ich glaub, das ist nicht so der
weiße als letzter Schluss, was ist das, ne, das muss man noch mal überlegen, ok, also,
gucken wir nochmal, guck mal was anderes, also USB hab, das schieb ich erstmal auf,
genau, dann wollt ich mir noch das, was wir letztens, wo wir letztens programmiert haben,
da wollt ich mir noch einen weiteren 3A-Pack kaufen, weil man macht ja schnell mal einen
kaputt und ich fand das Ding wirklich äußerst angenehm, da mit was zu basteln, was bezahlt
man da gerade bei Banggood für, Banggood, was ist das denn, ja, das sind aber nicht
die ESP32-Versionen, die ESP32-Versionen haben die hier irgendwie gar nicht, ne, Sauerei,
Anzeige ist raus, Banggood, das ist alle, hier, das ist ein ESP32, ok, der kostet natürlich
schon deutlich weniger als bei Amazon, ne, bei Amazon bezahlst du 6,66 das Stück und
bei Aliexpress bezahlst du 3,66, halt wie immer die Hälfte, aber die Delivery-Time ist
halt wieder jenseits von allem, ja, und Banggood hat irgendwie keine, warum hat Banggood keine,
Banggood, easy DHL ist mal 60 Euro, ja, ne, haben die nicht, hast du smarte E26 GU10-Lampen,
was sind denn GU10-Lampen, E27 ist die ganz normale Fassung oder ist es die kleine, ich
kann das immer nicht auseinander, was soll das sein, brauchen wir nicht, ein GU10, what,
hab ich noch nie gesehen, hab ich nicht, ich hab, ich hab zum größten, zwar nicht alles,
aber ich hab zum größten Teil, äh, so welche von denen hier, allerdings, allerdings nicht
die offenen, mit den offiziellen Preisen von der Homepage, weil, äh, die haben, die haben
sie nicht mehr alle, ja, was das hier kostet, da müsst ihr rumgucken, das kriegt ihr für
die Hälfte, pff, das ist der Witz, 64 Euro, das kriegst du für fast die Hälfte, wenn
du mal ein bisschen rumguckst, ne, die hab ich nicht geflasht, und man muss dazu sagen,
eigentlich ist es auch total übertrieben, denn, also ich glaube zumindest, die meisten
Leute übertreiben es total, man braucht in der Regel gar kein RGB, wie viele bekommt
man für 65 Euro, natürlich eine, was sonst, wie gesagt, du kriegst sie für die Hälfte
ungefähr, wenn du mal ein bisschen rumguckst, aber die würde ich auch nie kaufen, ähm,
für alles, weil die meisten Leute brauchen gar kein RGB, die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich
nur eine dimmbare Lampe haben, und, äh, dimmbare Lampen kosten halt nochmal deutlich weniger,
und da kannst du die auch holen, also, RGB ist eine coole Sache, aber braucht man bei
den meisten Sachen gar nicht, so, und wenn eine dimmbare Lampe nicht reicht, das nächste
ist, was die Leute haben wollen, vielleicht eine, wo du die Farbtemperatur einstellen
kannst, aber so richtiges RGB braucht man eigentlich ganz selten, weil, mal ernsthaft,
wo brauchst du richtiges RGB, wo willst du deine Decken, wo willst du deine Deckenlampe
auf grün schalten, das kommt nicht oft vor, das willst du vielleicht im Wohnzimmer, wenn
du irgendwie so Ambilight Extention oder sowas machst, aber ansonsten ist das doch jetzt
nicht so ein breites Anwendungsgebiet.
Im Streamingzimmer, äh, was im Streamingzimmer, Digga, Lost, Alter, richtig Lost hier die
Leute.
Kann man machen, aber ich behaupte mal, dass von, sagen wir mal, von 20, äh, so Smart-Wi-Fi-Lampen,
die sich jemand kauft, braucht er vielleicht fünf, und es ist jetzt vielleicht noch ein
bisschen zu hoch, fünf mit richtiges RGB, der Rest reicht dimmbar und eventuell dimmbar
mit Farbtemperatur, weil mit Farbtemperaturanpassung kannst du ja immer noch zwischen ein bisschen
weiß-pläulich und rötlich umschalten, das reicht ja in 99% der Fälle aus.
RGB ist, wenn du dein Zimmer lila machen willst oder so, was hältst du von Philips Hue, kann
ich nix zu sagen, hatte ich nie im Einsatz, so, ähm, ich brauch aber noch was, ich brauch
einen Aufsatz für mein, äh, ich hab so einen Heizluft, so ein Teil hier, ich bin mir nicht
mehr ganz sicher, welchen ich davon hab, wahrscheinlich den hier, ich brauch einen Aufsatz, der das
Ganze kleiner macht, das ist so groß vorne, und, äh, auch zu viel, zu viel Luft, ich brauch
so, ja, sowas hier, genau, sowas in der Richtung brauch ich, genau, genau, exell, ich hab so
im Prinzip ist das einfach nur Metalltrichter, oder, 9mm, ja, Nozzle, Nozzle, Rapid Reduction
Nozzle, oh, was denn das, oh, jetzt wird, jetzt wirds aber echt, jetzt wirds aber echt
Massive Advanced, was gibts denn hier alles, wofür genau brauch ich so, was, hä, was brauch
ich das denn alles für meinen Heizluft, was ist das überhaupt, hat irgendjemand ne, was
ist das Ding hier, ist das so, wo man so, wo man so aufs Knie Reflexe klopfen kann oder
wie, was ist das, Arschkratzer 14, ah, das ist wenn man jetzt einen juckt und man hat
die Hand voll, Crapmaker, ich erkennt auch nicht, na, die Dinger versteh ich ja, das
hier weiß ich sogar, also was das für ein Teil ist, keine Ahnung, aber wofür die Dinger
gut sind, weiß, kenn ich sogar, hier kannst du was zum Löten drüber legen und dann pustest
du und dann lötest du es zusammen, weil hier sich hier die heiße Luft staut, moin Max hast
du noch Kontakt zu iLoveCookies, warum fragst du das, hast du dich gestern schonmal gefragt,
wie kommst du denn da jetzt drauf, ich hab das auch by the way gestern glaub ich sogar
schon beantwortet, Schaber, Ersatz, was ist das alles, das ist so ein Schiener, boah,
Alter, willst du deine Wohnung abfackeln oder was, die China-Chinesen sind am Start,
das kommt mir nicht ins Haus, da fackelst du die Hütte ab, ist das ein April-Scherz,
das ist ein Witz, das heißt, es stinkt, ok, das ist ein April-Scherz, das ist ein April-Scherz,
damit lötest du doch nix, das ist ein Witz das Ding, oder, du schweißt damit doch nicht,
ok, anscheinend, anscheinend meinen die das wirklich ernst, Moment, das heißt wirklich,
es stinkt, oder was, das ist jetzt für mich jetzt kein guter Name für so ein Ding, wenn
es stinkt, ist in der Regel was kaputt, der Stream laggt, oh ne, laggt der Stream, Leute,
nope, der Stream laggt nix, null Drop-Frames, das liegt bei dir das Problem, gut, was auch
immer, also, ich hab keine Ahnung, was der Kram alles ist, ehrlich gesagt, Moment hier,
ich hab keine Ahnung was das alles ist, aber, wow, Moment, es hat eben noch 12 Euro gekostet,
warum kostet das auf einmal 49, 49 Euro für so ein paar Aufsätze, ne, ne, ne, ne, Leute,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, da nehm ich hier den kleinen Aufsatz, ich mein 5,30 für so ein Popelaufsatz
ist mir schon eigentlich zu teuer, das reicht, fertig, zack, das stand doch eben noch auf
bei 12 Euro, hier, ah, ich hab mich verguckt, 12,50, 49, null, null Triple U, okay, ich
hab nix gesagt, wegen deinem USB, guck dir mal USB Steckerleisten an, ne, das kann ich
ja nicht verwenden, ich brauch ja was, was ich über den USB Anschluss betreibe und nicht
in die Steckdose stecke, okay, den Kram haben wir jetzt, excellent, next, brauch ich schon
als nächstes nichts mehr, großartig, oder, ach doch, wo ich mir noch einen zweiten Satz
von kaufen will, aber da hab ich jetzt vergessen, wie das heißt, die Dinger sind richtig big
brain, äh, ähm, Schrumpf, Schlauch, der auch löten kann, Moment, wie hieß, wie heißen
die Dinger denn, Schlauch, ich hab vergessen, wie die Dinger heißen, aber die sind ultra
praktisch, da will ich mir noch einen Satz von kaufen, sowas hier, genau, Lötverbinder,
genau, da will ich mir, die Dinger sind richtig nice, hab ich jetzt schon ein paar mal verwendet
und sind richtig pock, übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema pock sind, ähm, wenn ich einen
Voice Assistant selbst machen würde, ne, den würd ich Poggers nennen, dann würd ich
sagen, hey Poggers, und dann würd ich dann sagen, was weiß ich, äh, die aktuelle Uhrzeit
ist 21.19, dann würd mir Poggers antworten und ich finde, das ist ein ausgefallener Name,
der versteht, der missversteht dann auch nicht irgendein Wort für Poggers und fühlt sich
angesprochen, also wenn ich mal irgendwie so ein Custom, äh, Voice Assistant mir aus
Guitar-Projekten zusammenbaue, dann wird der Poggers heißen, genau, was kann so ein Lötverbinder,
mein Gott, du brauchst ja ein Pop-Filter, ich brauch keinen Pop-Filter, ich brauch nur
ein Pop-Filter, wenn ich sag, wenn ich ja explizit rein poppe in das Mikrofon, das
hat ein Pop-Filter drauf, aber gegen mein Ultra, Ultra in das Mikrofon reingespräche
kann er nix machen, da ist ein Pop-Filter drauf, so, ich kann dir ja mal zeigen, was
ein Lötverbinder macht, äh, die Dinger sind richtig nice, der Bastel-Bruder, warte mal,
ich hab doch letztens ein Video gesehen von, äh, wie heißen die Dinger denn auf Englisch,
wie heißen die Dinger denn auf Solder, Join, Joints, genau, und da hab ich letztens erst
ein Video zu gesehen, und das war eigentlich ganz gut, weil er hat das auch durchgestricken,
Moment, wie heißt dieser Typ, Cleave, Dot, irgendwas, genau, Solder, Solder, da hab ich
das, hier, genau, der zeigt das eigentlich ganz gut, was das macht, äh, ich, ich scroll
jetzt mal ein bisschen vor, ne, also sprich, also, bei diesen Dinger funktioniert folgendermassen,
in der Mitte ist Lötzchen, hier außen ist ein Schrumpf-Schlauch, und das da, diese Farben,
das ist Heißkleber, also sprich, was passiert ist, ihr steckt, ich zeig's euch einfach
mal, ups, da klickt, 0W, genau, so, übrigens, der, guck, guck, der hat auch so einen Aufsatz
auf seinem Heißluftteil, das ist nur noch kleiner, kleiner gebläsebläst, ja, das muss
man nicht wirklich machen, ich mach das immer so, dass ich beides von, dass ich beides links
und rechts reinstecke, sodass es hier übereinander geht, aber Geschmackssache, so, genau, also,
du machst das da drüber, schiebst es da rein, so, und das hier ist Heißkleber, das blaue
ist Heißkleber, hier ist auch Heißkleber, und hier ist Lötzchen, was macht der denn
da, aufschieben, nein, das Ding, so, und jetzt hast du die Möglichkeit, entweder nimmst
ein Feuerzeug und hältst das dran, die letzten Schläuche hab ich alle mit dem Feuerzeug
gemacht, weil ich eben keinen Aufsatz für meinen Heißluftgebläse hatte, und das sonst
viel zu großflächig war, einfach ein Feuerzeug dranhalten, bisschen hin und her wackeln und
gut ist, und ein bisschen länger in die Mitte, dass du schmilzt, so, aber wenn er das jetzt
zeigt, dann sieht man, dass das echt eine gute Idee ist, Aufmach an, und jetzt Puststells
machen, damit das Cut 6 verlängern, das könntest du machen, aber für so ganz kleine Trädchen
wie bei Netzwerk ist das, brauchst du eine kleine Sache auch, ja, und die mögen das
ja auch nicht unbedingt, weil man die Isolierung aufmacht, aber ja, da würdest du wahrscheinlich
hinbekommen, aber um Cut 6 zu verlängern, würde ich wahrscheinlich irgendwie einen
Stecker nehmen, wo man das auf der einen Seite reinstecken, auf der anderen Seite reinstecken
gut ist, so, guck, jetzt gibt's Schrumpf, Schrumpfstells, Schrumpfstauchstells, und
das ist Heißkleber, der schmilzt jetzt und klebt das wasserdicht ab, also das ist eigentlich
eine richtig geile Idee, ich kauf mir kein Mikrofon, was auf dem Tisch, ich hab nen Mikrofon,
die Videos, hört ihr nicht den Unterschied, die Videos, die ich auf YouTube aufnehme,
nehm ich doch mit einem komplett anderen Mikrofon auf, als jetzt hier Stream, im Stream hab
ich meinen MMX300 auf, einfach weil es angenehm ist, hier drei Stunden zu hocken mit einem
Headset auf, wenn ich Videos für YouTube aufnehme, dann mach ich das mit meinem Ollen
Ploieti mit nem richtig dicken, fetten Popschutz obendrauf, so ein Puschel ist da obendrauf,
und der hier, das MMX300 hat halt so, hat ja auch nen Popschluss, Popschutz, so, also
wird geblasen, der Heißkleber klebt's wasserdicht ab, und jetzt in der Mitte volle Pulle, auch
das Mikrofon hat sich anders an, so, ok das ist ne andere Sorte als die die ich hab, weil
bei meinen, wenn ich hier das Feuerzeug, vielleicht macht das auch nicht heiß genug,
keine Ahnung, als ich das Feuerzeug dran gehalten hab, hab ich richtig gesehen, wie
das Lötzinn hier die Kabel lang gelaufen ist, aber es ist ne coole Technik, es ist
ne coole Idee, 20 Monate Kyo-Kun, Massive Subscriber, Dankeschön, 20 Monate, das ist
ja, so viel Hypersubscriber kann ich ja gar nicht drücken, äh, richtig Poggers, ja das
kommt mir auch vor als Heiz mit 50 Grad oder so, da geht ja überhaupt nix vorwärts, ja
doch, doch es schmilzt, es schmilzt, das wird wahrscheinlich schon so sein, 300 Grad
oder so, 250, 300 Grad, zumindest, dass er da dran greifen kann, normalerweise wird das
Kabel ganz schön warm, ne so richtig, so 100%ig gut schmelzen tut es nicht, ne, also wie gesagt
ich hab das, wir brauchen Omega-Sub, ja, ja, ja, also quasi die Kombination aus, ja genau
sowas, ja aber dafür sind die Dinger da und das ist ne echt coole Geschichte.
So, jetzt schneidet er es doch irgendwann durch und man sieht, dass es bei ihm überhaupt
nicht richtig zusammen gegangen ist, aber das ist auch ein relativ dickes Kabel muss
man sagen, was er da hat, ne, also das ist, das ist ziemlich Paynes-Champic, wenn du,
wenn du das, wenn du das von Hand löten würdest, wäre das schon ne ganze Ecke ordentlicher,
guckt also das ist, das er hat Kontakt, das ist zusammen, aber so schön ist es net, also
das ist von Hand gelötet definitiv besser, aber das Problem hatte ich da auch nicht,
ich hab das nur mit dünneren Kabel gemacht und da hab ich richtig gesehen, wie das Lötzinn
komplett durchs Kabel geflossen ist, das ist ein ganz schön dickes Kabel, was er da hat,
thick cable, so ein Ding, so ein Ding bräuchte ich mal, da suchen wir jetzt mal nach Amazon
dazu, ich hab zwar schon eine, aber die verwende ich nie, ich bräuchte sowas kleines, dritte
Hand löten und wir reden nicht hier, nicht wieder hier gleich unanständige Dinger posten
im Chat, so, was gibt's denn hier alles, mit Lupe, Lötrauchabsaugung, ok das ist cool,
die Sache ist plus die, wohin saugen das ab, oh fuck alter, was sind, was sind, 700 Schweizer
Franken zu Euro, 631 ok, wohin saugen das ab, ist da ein Filter drin oder wie ist das, ah
ok, oh das ist mir zu teuer, das ist mir zu teuer, wer atmet nicht gerne Lötdämpfe
ein, ich hab, wisst ihr was ich aktuell benutze, wisst ihr was ich aktuell benutze, um Löt,
Wolken abzusaugen, den USB Ventilator Champ, sowas da, das zieht, das pustet es dann einfach
im Raum rum und danach wenn ich fertig bin mache ich Fenster auf, einfach einen USB Ventilator
Nehmer gestellt, ich will keinen Schlauch aus dem Fenster legen, aber sowas hier bräuchte
ich ernsthaft mal, ich hab welche, also ich hab sowas, allerdings nur sowas, das hat auch,
also das was ich hab, hat auch solche Ärme, das Dumme ist nur, dass man die quasi entweder
am Tisch, also du musst quasi am Tisch was festschrauben um das dann zu machen, das ist
total unbequem, das verwende ich nicht, ich würde eher sagen, also ich hätte lieber sowas
was ich auf den Tisch stellen kann, einfach zwei Kabel zusammen, es wird ja immer abgedrehter,
sowas hier, sowas hier bräuchte ich mal ne, die Lupe und das gedöns brauche ich net,
ich bräuchte einfach sowas zum festhalten, aber nicht mit so viel Schnickschnack dabei,
einfach ein paar Zangen, also das sieht ja aus wie aus irgendeinem Hentai oder so, das
da Kram, wo ist eigentlich das Sebaro, wenn man da von solchen Sachen spricht, gib ein
Löthilfe, da kommt der gleiche Crap, oh das ist bestimmt qualitativ sehr hochwertig
für 3.70, gibt es das auch mit RGB, wir wissen ja, dass mit RGB prinzipiell alles besser
wird, Lötkolbenset für 18.99, da ist auch, ist da noch Multimeter dabei oder was, ne,
die Chinesen wieder, bestimmt auch ultra hochwertiges Zeug, sieht aus wie ein Gerät
beim Zahnarzt, LED brauche ich nicht, das steht bei mir alles unter dem Elgato Ringlight,
gibt es nicht einfach was total Simples, sowas hier vielleicht, einfach was total Simples,
so ein bisschen Gewicht und einfach zwei Dinger zum Clipsen und gut ist, ne Lupe brauche ich
eh nicht, Hauptsache billig, Alter das sieht ja echt pervers aus das Zeug, wisst ihr was
ich machen sollte, ich hab ja sowas hier in der Richtung schon, sowas ähnliches, sowas
ähnliches wie das hier hab ich ja schon, ich könnte einfach dauerhaftes an mein Basteltisch
dran machen und halt permanent dran lassen, hol dir lieber sowas was aussieht wie ne GoPro
sowas da, was hat der da oben, Moment ist das ein PC Lüfter, Moment ist das die Massive
Brain Absaugung oder wie, wenn das schon nicht mehr reicht, dass man das einatmet, wenn man
das explizit ins Gesicht geblasen bekommen will oder wie, by the way der Lüfter hat
jetzt gar nicht angeschlossen, ja Tentakel Shit und nur mal, dass ich das richtig verstehe,
dass da unten ist ein Gewicht oder wie, wie kriege ich das an Tisch dran, Smoke Fan Suck
den Smoke, ja der Suck den Smoke, wohin in dein Gesicht, in your Face Suck der, das ist
ja ne billige Konstruktion Alter, das sieht aus wie ein Meme Bild, ja ist es anscheinend
aber nicht, die meinen das ernst, guck mal das bläst dir voll ins Gesicht, wenn du da
dahinten, ok du kannst natürlich in die andere Richtung machen, aber das ist meine, WTF,
viermal Absaugung, ach ne das ist ne Drohne, ich dachte halt das ist viermal Absaugungsdinger,
ich hoffe das ist relativ schwer unten, dass das auch ordentlich steht, wie schwer, wie
viel wiegt denn das, ich weiß nicht, hier ein halbes Kilo, ist die Base magnetisch,
vielleicht ist es gar nicht so schlecht, vielleicht ist es wirklich gar nicht so übel, die finden
es alle voll geil, also habe ich es richtig verstanden, irgendjemand aus dem Chat hat
das so ein Teil, oder? Tentakel Champ, ja Hentai Champ, ah ja ja gefällt dies, du hast
es richtig gut, das ist das USB-Kabel für diesen billigen, für diesen komischen Mainboard-Lüfter,
das sieht echt fail aus mit diesem Mainboard oder mit diesem komischen Mini-Router-Switch-Lüfter
und komische Konstruktion auf jeden Fall, vor allem wie sich erstmal das Kabel ablötet
hier ne, erstmal schönes Kabel über den Lötkolben hängen, was ist die beste Steckdose
zum Stromverbrauch auszulesen, ja eine die du flashen kannst, aber da ist immer schwierig
was zu finden, es sei denn du willst C-Wave verwenden, für C-Wave habe ich eine super
Steckdose, davon habe ich auch mindestens 5 Stück im Haus, da habe ich die hier, weil
bei C-Wave ist es ja nämlich so, bei Notebooks billiger gab es die, weil bei C-Wave ist es
ja so, dass jedes Gerät was an der Steckdose steckt, das Netzwerk erweitert, kannst du
ein Emoji-Font für mancher, wo man weit weg geht alle Emojis abdecken kann, also ich habe
habe ich hier einen Emoji-Font installiert, ah ne das ist Firefox, Firefox hat einen Emoji-Font
mit dabei, Moment habe ich schon einen Emoji-Font hier installiert, müssen wir mal im Terminal
probieren, nein habe ich nicht Leute, ich habe keinen Emoji-Font installiert, doch habe
ich, habe ich, okay probieren wir mal aus, gibt es einen Emoji-Test-Skript, Github-Bash
oder ShitHub-Bash Emoji-Test, gibt es doch bestimmt irgendeine Schleife, Emoji-Test
jawoll zeig her, was macht der da, ich will einfach, ich will einfach ein Programm was
einfach alle Emojis ausgibt die es gibt und dann gucken was auf der Shell funktioniert
was nicht, was ist das, ah Crap, okay wir können was anderes machen, ich habe die Idee
was wir machen Leute, wir machen Wim auf Bloop Emoji.txt und wir kopieren jetzt einfach
die komplette Seite da rein easy, so und jetzt gucken wir was geht, oh ich glaube das ist
kaputt gegangen beim kopieren, Moment, Moment Leute, Set, Paste, ah yes, aber ein paar Sachen
sind immer noch kaputt, na hoffen wir mal dass das jetzt funktioniert, okay also, okay
ich würde sagen der Emoji-Font ist relativ komplett, richtig pfeifert, ich würde sagen
der Emoji-Font ist tatsächlich ziemlich komplett den ich hier habe, guck mal der kann sogar
verschiedene Farbton Emojis, ja das ist so nice, kannst du Black Facing im Terminal
machen, aber ist fast alles dabei, sind Länderflaggen dabei, Länderflaggen, haben wir Länderflaggen,
Länderflaggen haben wir nicht oder Flex, ah Moment die stehen nicht auf der Hauptseite
oder doch, haben wir Länderfahnen, nein Länderfahnen haben wir nicht, okay Länderfahnen
funktionieren nicht, okay Länderfahnen kann mein Emoji-Font nicht, was habe ich denn
für den Emoji-Font, TTF Joypixels, alternativ, ich glaube der funktioniert im Terminal nicht,
was ich habe den hier, TTF Joypixels, ich überlege gerade ob es vielleicht eine neue
Version von gibt, Joypixel, nein gibt es nicht, okay also das Ding, ich glaube man
braucht mittlerweile gar nichts mehr zusätzlich großartig konfigurieren, einfach den Emoji-Font
installieren und gut ist, ich glaube der bringt eine Font-Konfig mit, dass er funktioniert,
ja easy, aber leider keine Flaggen wie es aussieht, brauchen wir nicht oft, aber es
wäre cool wenn der Emoji-Font wirklich einfach alles könnte, aber der hat nicht alle drinne,
also die ganz neuen, aber guck mal der hat sogar, nee guck mal die hat er nicht drinne,
die hat er nur zum Teil drinne, er hat welche drinne, er hat welche drinne von 2020, aber
hat keine ganz neuen von 2021 drinne und Flaggen hat er auch nicht, dafür hast du Emoji
in allen möglichen Hauttönen und ansonsten alle Standard Emojis, ja passt doch, also
ich würde sagen damit kommt man eigentlich ganz gut aus, man muss nämlich gucken wenn
man Emojis im Terminal haben will, man kann nicht, man kann nicht irgendwas nehmen, ist
doch nur ein Hautton, nee nicht nur ein Hautton, du hast die Emojis in schwarz, du hast die
Emojis in, du hast die Emojis in schwarz, du hast die in dunkel, brauner und zwei Weißtöne
und die Standarddinger in, ach nee Moment, ich bin dumm, das stimmt ja gar nicht, das
kann er nicht, ok da kann er das nicht, ihr habt recht, das ist ja die Geschichte mit,
wenn der Emoji-Font das kann, dann gibt das hier eine weiße Hand und das hier gibt eine
schwarze Hand, ok der Emoji-Font kann das doch nicht, cut das mal, ne guck das kann
er nicht, wobei ich da gar nicht weiß ob das an dem Emoji-Font liegt, dass der das nicht
kann, probieren wirs mal im Chrome aus, es könnte auch einfach sein, dass das ein Problem
vom Terminal ist, doch, der Emoji-Font kann das, weil Chrome verwendet den ja auch, das
liegt jetzt am Terminal, dass es das nicht kann, guck mal und der kann sogar Länderflagen,
dass das Terminal hat damit irgendwelche Probleme oder sind das andere, Moment sind das andere
Emojis als im, ne ne das sind die schon hier, der Chrome verwendet nämlich den System Emoji-Font
und der Firefox, Firefox bringt einen eigenen mit, deswegen sehen die unterschiedlich aus,
by the way habe ich euch schon mal gesagt, dass Emoji-Fonts und generell diese, wie
das dargestellt wird, ein absolutes Minenfeld ist, es ist total wir, es gibt wieder 4 verschiedene
Standards dafür und blickt keiner durch und die sind dann untereinander nicht zueinander
kompatibel, vielleicht liegt es an T-Max, das könnte sein, aber dann sollte eher gar
nichts gehen, das probieren wir mal aus, Emoji, ne, liegt nicht an T-Max, liegt vielleicht
am Terminal, ich mein wir können mal einen Xterm starten, der kann wahrscheinlich, was
zum Teufel ist das, nicht Boy, wie heißt das Ding, ach das ist dieser, das ist dieses
Fake T-Max, warum habe ich das überhaupt installiert, will ich nicht, weg damit,
geht nicht, weil Break-Dependency, ach Hollywood braucht das, ok dann kann ich es nicht installieren,
weil wir wissen, dass Hollywood auf jeden Fall eines der wichtigsten Programme ist, die
man auf jedem Linux System braucht, weil nur so kann man echter Hacker-Man sein, ok dann
muss ich das installiert lassen, geht nicht anders, seid ihr schon drin Chat, wer ist
schon drin, also ich bin schon lange drin, vor allem diese komische World-Map hier unten,
die sind auch drin, sehr gut, ab wann zählt man nicht mehr als Junior-Entwickler,
boah, ich würde sagen zwei Jahre, so eine genaue Definition gibt es da nicht, zwei Jahre
Erfahrung, dann bist du eigentlich kein Junior-Entwickler mehr, würde ich jetzt einfach was aus dem
Bauch raussagen, ohne dass ich das jetzt irgendwie belegen könnte oder belastbare Beweise, Erfahrungsberichte
dafür hätte, was bringt das Programm außer gut auszusehen, nix, nix, nix, aber es ist
wichtig, für die echten Hacker-Mans, die brauchen das, tja, ach guck mal, FireFox kann die allerneusten
Emojis auch nicht, was soll denn bei diesen Emojis eigentlich rauskommen, wenn es fertig
ist, was soll denn da sein, Emoji 13, also ich vermute mal, dass das sowas wie Gay Pride
oder so ist, was gibt es denn, sag mal, Couple Man with Heart, das ist ein Zeichen, nee oder,
boah, das ist aber das breiteste, den breitesten Character, den ich je gesehen habe, okay,
das kann das Terminal auch nicht, das Terminal ist nicht in der Lage, das richtig anzuzeigen,
und das jetzt auch alles noch in unterschiedlichen Skin-Tones, gut ey, ich meine Unicode ist
groß, da kannst du im Prinzip noch alles reinpacken, aber das ist jetzt nicht, oder, doch, das
soll so aussehen, also die Aussage dahinter verstehe ich, aber die Emoji-Umsetzung finde
ich un-inspiriert irgendwie, das sind einfach die normalen Emojis nur in einem Character,
ah, Moment, Moment, die haben das alle bloß noch nicht implementiert, die haben das alle
nicht implementiert, mein Fond zeigt das nur so an, weil das noch kein extra Bild dafür
hat, so wird es dann später mal aussehen, okay, das ist was anderes, dann leuchtet mir
das jetzt auch ein, weil ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist ultra un-inspiriert, da kann
ich einfach vier Zeichen hintereinander machen und gut ist, das ist was, da habe ich keine
Schmerzen mit, dass es das gibt, doch eigentlich kann man, man hat so einen riesen, man hat
so einen riesen Unicode-Zeichen Vorrat, da kann man sowas doch auch reinmachen, wo man
sich jetzt drüber streiten kann, ist, braucht man das jetzt wirklich in allen nur erdenklichen
Varianten, wenn ihr mich fragt, ich war ja persönlich ein Fan von, dass Emojis gelb
sind, warum, weil das so eine abstrakte Farbe ist, so sieht halt keiner in echt aus, niemand
hat so eine Hautfarbe in echt, deswegen fand ich das eigentlich ganz cool, dass einfach
die Standard Emojis und auch die viele Smiley Bilder, dass das einfach gelb war, das war
dann so quasi, konntest du im Prinzip international verwenden für alles, danach hat man ja gesagt,
ok, die Chinesen, Quatsch, chat, die Chinesen, sieht auch kein Chinese aus, so eine Hautfarbe
hat schlicht und ergreifend keiner, außer vielleicht einer, der irgendwie einen Ausschlag
hat oder so, deswegen fand ich das eigentlich ganz cool, man hat dann aber das Fass aufgemacht
und hat quasi angefangen, die zusätzliche Codes hinten dran zu machen, dass die Emojis
quasi passende Hautfarbe haben, so und als man damit angefangen hat, war klar, wenn man
jetzt neue Emojis einführt, dann muss man die auch immer gleich in 5 verschiedenen Hauttönen
mit einführen, kann man machen, Unicode ist groß genug, ist halt Pain in the Ass für
Leute, die das implementieren müssen, ich finde es nicht schlimm, dass es das gibt,
ich finde es aber ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen unnötig, ich finde im Internet können wir
alle gelb sein, vollkommen in Ordnung, wir streiten uns schon oft genug über irgendwelche
unterschiedlichen Sachen, warum sind wir nicht im Internet einfach alle gelb, jemand mit
kaputter Leber sieht so aus, kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber das wäre doch schon äußerst
ungesund, wenn das so aussehen würde, oder?
So, wir sehen dann, ok, neue, das muss man gerade mal gucken, new Emojis, was kam da sonst
noch so dabei, Face Exhaling, sieht dann wie aus so, Moment, Joypixels kann das angeblich,
Face Exhaling, warum kann es mein Joypixels nicht, mein Joypixels kann es Face Exhaling
nicht, oder aber, oder aber mein Terminal kann das nicht, das ist die große Preisfrage,
Face Exhaling muss ich jetzt, muss ich haben, Face Exhaling kann mein Font nicht, Anzeige
ist raus, angeblich kann Joypixels, kann das, warum, warum kann das mein Font nicht, scammed,
was gibt's, ich brauch einen anderen Font, Font, ich brauch einen neuen Emoji Font, ich
brauch einen, der Face Exhaling kann, Leute, geht mir nicht, Chat, Chat, regt euch ab,
soll jeder denken, was er will, wenn ihr was richtig findet, ok, ich ignoriere schon, ich
ignoriere Twitter schon, weil ich keinen Bock auf diese Diskussion hab, die hängen, die
stehen mir echt, ich hab absichtlich mein Twitter auf Andorra gestellt, ich hab keinen
Bock auf diese Diskussion, soll einfach jeder machen, was er will und soll es nicht den
anderen aufzwängen und gut ist, das geht nicht, das geht nämlich in Terminal nicht, die kann
man nicht im Terminal verwenden, weil, wie gesagt, es gibt vier verschiedene Implementierungen,
wie man Emoji Fonts machen kann und die sind nicht alle zueinander kompatibel und das,
der Gnome Terminal Font Renderer, ich glaub, wahrscheinlich ist es Pango, der kann nur
verschiedene bestimmte Formate und der kann beispielsweise nicht das Google Format, das
ist richtig painstamp, es gibt fünf verschiedene Formate, es gibt einen Google Format, einen
Apple Format, einen Adobe Format und einen Microsoft Format, passt mal auf, das ist richtiger
painstamp, die könnten sich was vom USB Forum angucken, Twitter, nee, Twitter hat einen
eigenen Font, aber verwendet ein Standard von einem der anderen beiden, eher genau so
heißen die Dinger, also es gibt SVG in OpenType, das kann nur Edge und Firefox, es gibt Collezipal,
das können alle Browser, dann gibt es SBX, das ist Apple, glaube und dann gibt es noch
CBTD und CBLC, Edge kann alle, ja aber der Gnome Edge nicht, seht ihr mal, das ist wirklich
Pain in the Ass Emoji Fonts, so und ich glaube, dass das da nicht im Gnome Terminal geht,
also die Google, außerdem finde ich die Google Emojis nicht schön, Leute, change my mind,
aber die Twitter Emojis sind die optisch schönsten, die hier, die Google mag ich gar nicht, Google
Emojis gefallen mir persönlich überhaupt nicht, Microsoft finde ich auch dumm und Apple
ist gut, Apple ist auch gut, also Apple und Twitter, ich muss sagen, die Twitter Emojis
gefallen mir am besten gefolgt von Apple, kann man sich darüber streiten, was schöner
ist, aber ich mag den, also mir gefallen die Twitter Emojis am besten, das sind übrigens
die gleichen, die man hier auch in FFZ glaube hat, also hier im Chat, das sind glaube auch
die Twitter Emojis, was ist das für ein Font, Tweemoji, ja, ja, Twitter Emojis sind das,
jetzt mal unabhängig davon, ob ihr Apple Fan oder nicht Apple Fan oder was auch immer
sein, welche sind euch lieber, also wir haben zur Auswahl Twitter, Apple, Microsoft oder
Google, Microsoft wirklich, ok, da sieht man mal, wie unterschiedlich der Geschmack ist
oder, Microsoft sind am cleansten, ich mag die Microsoft Emojis überhaupt gar nicht,
Apple, da sieht man mal, wie unterschiedlich die Geschmäcker sind, also wir sind uns alle
einig, dass die Apple Emojis, also was heißt alle einig, aber viele schreiben Apple, also
ich glaube die meisten mögen Apple Emojis, bei mir ist es so, bei mir sind die auf dem
zweiten Platz und ich mag Twitter am meisten, vor allem ich finde den hier viel besser als
bei, also generell diese Sorte ja viel, viel, viel besser gemacht als bei Apple, aber ja,
TTF Tweemoji, ja aber die gehen im Terminal nicht, die gehen im Terminal nicht, sonst
hätte ich den schon, ich habe das vor einer ganzen Weile mal durch probiert und das einzige
was funktioniert easy im Terminal ist Joypixels oder Emoji One früher, was steht hier genau
im Terminal, no, Job Support, ernsthaft, warum entfernen die immer irgendwelche Features,
ach ne, das geht um andere Sachen, die Blob Emojis mochte ich auch nicht, also ganz ehrlich
mir haben die Google Emojis auch nie gefallen, ok hier steht was die was können, ok, siehste
Tweemoji ist SVG und SVG, mein Pango kann, kann SVG, nein Pango kann das was Freetype
kann, genau und Firefox, und Firefox kann, Firefox ist, die haben zusätzlich noch die
Unterstützung dafür genau, bei einer halben Stunde geht es um die Emojis ja, ich würde
ohne Scheiß, ich würde ultra gerne die Twitter Emojis im Terminal verwenden, aber es funktioniert
nicht, ist halt echt doof ne, hast keine Chance, weil das kein SVG kann, es müsste halt einfach
nur jemand, was heißt einfach, einfach nur sich jemand hinsetzen, Moment, wait a minute,
geht das, oder sind es die schwarz-weißen, Moment sind es die schwarz-weißen, was ist
das, Moment, wait a minute, geht das jetzt, ok das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, ich mach
erstmal nen Snapshot bevor ich meine Font-Config verhaue, Moment Moment mal, Snapshot, excellent,
jetzt jetzt, ok wir installieren das alte, JoyPixel, ne wie ist das Ding, das muss ich
jetzt ausprobieren, ich will Twitter Emojis im Terminal haben, jo, JoyPixels, weg damit,
hab ich irgendeine Custom Font-Config, Font-Config oder so, hab ich keine extra, keine extra
Font-Config, wo liegen die Digger, der etc, Font-Config, Fonts, hab ich da irgendwelche
Custom, Customized Dinger, ich hoffe nicht, etc, grab, Joy, hab ich da irgendwas gemacht,
Alter ich kann da mal tippen, ne anscheinend nicht, ok, dann installier ich das Ding jetzt
mal, also was muss man jetzt hier denn das da, ja ey wenn ich, das wäre doch mal richtig
poggers, Twitter Emojis im Terminal, da wart ich die ganze Zeit schon drauf, gibs mir, ok
to prevent conflicts with other Emoji Fonts, das war beste, das fasst so gut wie der Ertinger,
to prevent conflicts with other Emoji Fonts, it's not being automatically installed in
Emoji Fonts, if you don't use any Emoji Fonts, simply make a swimlink, machen wir, bam und
jetzt müssen wir wahrscheinlich mal rebooten, sag bloß das funktioniert, ey das wäre poggers,
wenn ich jetzt Twitter Emojis hätte im Terminal, seitdem ich meinen Model S in der Garage stehen
hab ist der natürlich Custom Firmware geflasht, was meint ihr dann, meint ihr ich fahr mein
Auto mit Stock Firmware, nie im Leben Alter, achso Chat wollen wir Prediction machen, wollen
wir Prediction machen ob es geht, Mod Check, Mod Check, Prediction gehen die Twitter Emojis
im Terminal oder nicht, gehen Twitter Emojis im Terminal, ja nein, Prediction, Prediction
startet, können wir predikten, wir müssen ja ein paar neue Twitch Features ausnutzen,
ok es ist ziemlich 50-50, es ist komplett 50-50 mehr oder weniger, ja 48, 52, 48, oh what
the fuck, jetzt ist es instant ge-switched auf ja, alles klar, jetzt ist 85% ja, 90%
ja, seid ihr euch da so sicher, es ist Linux, da geht eigentlich selten was auf den ersten,
ok, 89% meinen es geht, 11% meinen nein, ok, Terminal, Cat Emoji, Moment funktioniert
es jetzt oder nicht, es funktioniert, es sind Twitter Emojis im Terminal, das ist ja ultra
nice, das wollte ich schon immer haben, huge, gut ich meine die Unicore Dinger die das Terminal
nicht richtig entschlüsseln kann, passt aber, Flaggen hat er auch noch nicht, nice Twitter
Emojis im Terminal, jawoll, endlich, da warte ich schon lange drauf, das wichtigste, jetzt
kann ich endlich meine Git Commits auch ordentlich mit Emojis ausstatten, jawoll, ah yes, exquisite,
exquisit oder so haben wir letztens gelernt, heißt das, exquisite, exquisite, exquisit,
ich kann das immer noch nicht, am exquisitesten, haben wir extra letztens nachgeguckt, wie man
das korrekt steigert, ja, ich bin begeistert, endlich Twitch, nicht, was labere ich denn
Twitch, Alter, Twitter, man fängt das auch mit den gleichen Buchstaben an, im Terminal,
so ist das nice, so mag ich das, gut, kann ich den Snapshot auch gleich wieder löschen,
weil das hat ja alles funktioniert, by the way das ist der Grund was für Forever Workstation
spricht, versus Player, Snapshots sind viel zu geiles Feature, huge, ein absolut massive
Feature, also ich verwende zsh, also ich verwende zsh, zsh, zshelm, wie spricht man das eigentlich
genau aus, ich schreibe das immer nur, nein verwende ich nicht, ich habe nur selbst ein
bisschen Konfig rumgewurstet und fertig, ich habe eigentlich nur einen Custom Prompt, das
war's, Fraid Wilhelm, 6 Monat Dankeschön für den Sub, Leute ihr wisst was jetzt für
Zeit ist, ihr wisst was für eine Zeit ist, oder, ich gehe jetzt pennen, ich glaube der
Katz hat noch was zu fressen, machen wir noch ein bisschen Spielaction mit der Katz, Reifenwechsel
ist jetzt angesagt, genau, also Chat, wir sehen uns bis der NCU.
Wir sehen uns bis der NCU.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.